okay well welcome to the lecture today
and today we're going to do some game
analysis and I have a game submitted by
Julian last week and this is against
Alex Richter okay and this was I believe
just a lot of game okay
so Julian here he is white and he's
playing 2,200
okay d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 93 Bishop b4
raise your hand if you know the name of
this opening here okay not everybody
knows so it's good to good to go over
these things because more openings you
know even if you know the first two
moves it's still good like this opening
is called the nimzo-indian defense okay
so black as soon as he plays Bishop
before it's a names of Indian defense if
they ask you here what's the name of the
opening what do you say unclear because
there are several different openings can
still happen here so let's take a look
here black can play c5 and that would be
benoni
benoni defense it can also play the move
d5 which will transpose into which
opening Queens gambit declined so we
have two different Queens gambit
openings Queens gambit declined and
Queens gambit accepted and they can also
play the move Bishop before this is the
best move in my opinion this is the move
that Allah I like to play in tournaments
name so Indian is a very solid opening
choice in my opinion so Julian played
Queen c2 classical setup
and what is the main idea behind this
move there are two things that this move
accomplishes what are the two things
that this move this move does okay
protects protects efore Square and in
new zone Indian defense this is a very
important Square black wants to get the
night here on e4 so it's like a battle
white is trying to control the e4 square
and black trying to do the same and
usually whoever wins that battle for the
e4 square he will have a good position
so Queen c2 protects the e4 square
that's one of the ideas but what is the
main idea that this move does exactly
see when he takes here you have a choice
you can take back with the pawn or you
can take back with the Queen you don't
want to take back with a pawn because
two problems the first problem is you
create the weak pawn here and you have
double puns you never want to get a
double pawns
unnecessarily okay if you have a choice
try to avoid having double pawns because
they are usually weak pawns
so that's why you want to take back with
the Queen in this position and that's
the main reason why you play Queen c2
this is a move actually that I play and
I like this move and I think this is the
best one because most of the time after
you play a three-block is going to take
on c3 and you take back with the Queen
in this position and you have the pair
of the bishops and that's a considered
an advantage to have the pair of the
bishops castles and Julian plate Knight
f3 here
why not a3 you weren't sure about a
theory or you had some other ideas
because usually when you play 90 Q this
is what you're supposed to do
okay
neither three is fine I myself played it
this move so it's a fine move it is just
the main move here is a tree yeah okay
make sense because he played this I
think similar move against him as well
against me in the last year US
Championships oh okay you could play
Knight f3
mm-hm it's possible so here black played
d5 plays d5 another move here is c5
so d5 is played Bishop g5 by Julian it's
a good idea to develop the bishop and
pin because you don't want to play e3 in
this position because if you play e3
what is the problem with this move here
it looks like a normal move protecting
the center but it creates a little
problem so what is the problem do you
see the problem with this move backward
issue so basically you block your own
bishop here so your bishop cannot come
out and this Bishop it's going to be
passive in some lines you play this move
but in this particular position you
don't have to play this move so if you
have a choice if you have a choice
always develop the bishop first and then
play III in some lines you don't have
time to do that but in this position you
can play three and in this position you
can play Bishop g5 so you know you have
to see in which positions you can do
that and when you don't want to do it
so you play Bishop g5 h6 questioning the
bishop now White has two options
basically either to take but black just
takes back and doesn't look like white
is accomplishing that much
so you decided to go back h4 and now b6
yeah I think I'm not sure if black is
playing this correctly because looks
like you're going to have a pretty nice
position after this absolutely
absolutely
yeah black should try to play something
different not be d7 perhaps or some c5
ideas this b6 is not very good and you
played correctly you took now forcing
the capture back with a pawn because
Knight cannot capture because of the pin
so he takes back with a pawn he plays
III rook e8 Bishop d3 Knight bd7
Castle we should be 7 so now you played
a tree which makes sense but I'm not
sure this this bishop is actually placed
here really well so when you play a3 you
might be actually forcing to go back to
a better square what is the most logical
thing to do here for white if you attend
my lectures before I always talk about
that the importance of completing the
development and I feel like in this
position Julian you you you could have
complete your development first and then
think about a tree or trying to do
something else which two pieces white
still needs to develop here so he has
complete development rooks remember
complete development before you start
attack so these two pieces not developed
here right so when you have a chance you
got to develop them and here the first
move in my opinion it's pretty obvious
what to do when you want to develop your
rook you want to develop it to an open
file
and if you don't have an open file you
develop it to an half Open File semi
open file and that's a 1 so we go rook a
to c1 next we go to FD 1 we have
complete development and then we think
about the next what we're going to do
okay because the meantime he cannot do
too much if you have a very nice
position you have two great bishops you
have the center you have diagonal you
have half open file here so this is a
stable a slightly better position for
white and very comfortable
okay did you thought about playing this
move
but that's what you want see that's
that's what we want we want him actually
to take on c3 and then we take back who
has the pair of the bishops now yeah I
understand that's probably your idea but
something like this it's actually a big
advantage here
it's not even slide this is a big
advantage because you have better
development more active pieces and the
pair of the bishops so it's very
important to pay attention this the pair
of the bishops because sometimes you
don't realize that this this is a real
strength for you here when you have the
pair of the bishops okay then you go to
cavity one and every piece you have is
perfectly developed you know I wouldn't
worry at all about this take you just
take back with the Queen and okay you
shouldn't worry about him taking more c3
you know you'll be glad if you play a
tree and he still takes so this is
important moment okay so next time just
remember this is for everyone
complete your development get all the
pieces together okay
so a tree bishop f8 same thing I'm
seeing here same thing I'm seeing Bishop
f5 now ok activating this should be
seven rook a c1 spine rook f d1
rook AC one root f d1 here white has a
you know slightly better position here
and it's clear it's clear that white has
better development more active pieces
you just need to find a good plan after
this so you certainly want the opening
bottle in this game
Knight h5 this seems like an inaccuracy
no okay 90 h5 opponent is putting the
knight on the side of the board which
potentially could be weak and and
hanging here so you decided to go Bishop
takes c7 Bishop takes is 7
you also had Bishop takes d7 that you
had to consider just queen is 6m yeah
okay
so you took Bishop e7 queen is 7 queen a
queen a 424 is a possible move
definitely but it seems like it's time
to play your main idea the reason you
play the a3 was to play then do it gain
space very important to gain space so
that's why we play b4
yeah yeah it's good to create threads
but sometimes you need to play a little
bit deeper like with a plum instead of
just make one move and create a thread
okay Julian goes here who can see his
thread here
think about it aha very good the thread
is let's say blacks make makes adjuster
just a move just an example
Knight takes d5 tactic takes back and
now how many attackers we have on this -
so we take the pawn this is what you're
but you didn't expect him to miss this
do you know what why why Julian night a
night h2 f6 this is the mood that you
should look the night is on the room not
doing anything he can bring it back into
the game and protect okay so that's a
move like Queen a force it's don't play
for like a one move trick
I could play Knight takes d5 here I
didn't because some quite a deep idea
but I have to say I'm not even sure if
this works there is 95 move here this
Bishop c8 move here when when you have
this tactics that it just seemed too
complicated and unreal a now you should
maybe not to go too deep about it okay
because when you try to play too
complicated too too fancy and clever
away sometimes you actually end up
missing some ideas some simple ways to
play Lexie you were thinking about some
complicated sacrifice but on the other
hand he just takes your knight and you
don't have anything okay so clean a fort
I don't think it put this pieces placed
here really well here okay so you
shouldn't have enough play that you
should have played a four so now you go
92 yeah
92 Knight is okay here the other thing
you need to move the knight I think it's
still time to play before here you need
to get before
okay so 92 played by Julian a 694 2693
g6 wish of h3
Bishop h3 plate okay it's probably fine
yeah well another idea was to capture
maybe even before first because I don't
want to allow him to place c5 if I can
yeah
yeah but the problem with this move you
allow c5 now black managed to get c5 and
this is what he's been trying to do
because his bishop on b7 was bad and
finally he gets to play c5 and this is a
little bit of a freedom for him okay
let's see if you cannot do anything
right away then yeah then it's okay but
you played what 55 putting pressure
Knight f8 aha
you took x-pac 95 now you're attacking
the bishop 2594 24 so it looks great for
you and looks like here have very good
winning chances here white is up upon
managed to win upon enter good winning
chances rook d b8
Knight C 595 rook c5 rook be to rook
takes Wow how did you lose this game did
you lose this game yeah I remember you
told me you lost this game but now it's
hard to believe look in the disposition
that you lost this your upper pond and
you have a better minor piece which
minor piece is better bishop or Knight
here bishop right because it's simply
cutting him off see it's cutting the
squares of the night can't go here can't
go here
and wait wait wait he had one minute you
how much time you have five so you have
five minutes here's one minute you have
a winning position you don't need to do
any any complicated anything you just
need to play simple chess
exchange pieces win another pond and
pose problems don't try to play on his
time this is the biggest mistake you
could do when your opponent is long time
you start thinking I got a trick him I
gotta do something maybe he'll miss it
you don't do that you just play good
moves continue playing good moves okay
so you're winning here already you don't
need to you know do anything really
special just need to make good moves and
you will win this game g3 was played
rook C to g3 rook c7
no group p8u decided to exchange rook
p3a for you playbook a tree or root
before and we don't have anymore
notation so this is where you start
notating so I assume you played rugby
for here okay and tell us how you lose
this game
okay wait he gave you the pond - okay
great
okay I believe
okay
roopd five you could do rooty five if
you like many things you can do here we
can go kingi to prophylaxis the only way
you can lose if somehow you get into
some mating net here that's the only way
I can see you lose this if somehow he
gets you with some mating net you mean
earlier okay
now what York is hanging so g95 and I
played Bishop b5 our Bishop e7
Oh almost found the only way to lose it
only way to lose in the back door yeah
pity because you know you okay this is
the authority you may a little bit
harder to win this position but it's a
it's certainly winnable here okay who
can find a winning move here I see a
very nice move here why don't you start
with this move maybe you didn't like
Roque too did you
and now what's the winning move here
after this move it will be completely
clear that white is just winning who can
find a winning move here that will
eliminate the whole control play Justin
Justin go excellent sacrificing the
bishop to eliminate the threats he takes
you take back absolute pin he cannot
move he has to play f6 and now what's
the best piece to use to attack a pinned
piece pawn right there you go
that's it eliminate the piece three
extra pawn in our heat that that's when
you you know I have game like this like
to you know sometimes you know like even
the last year's championship I had a
game that you know was completely
winning then I think you know then it
was a draw then somehow I managed to
lose if you think about I can never lose
then somehow you find a way to lose
that's what I did in that game I think
you should play Bishop e2 here should be
should be a win here okay okay here we
go this is the game that Justin played
here and who are you playing Oh
after the game okay you are white or
black okay he is playing white against a
mysterious player here strong player
okay efore c5 Sicilian defense one of
the most popular openings in chess
Knight f3
g6 yeah this is not the most common move
here usually black plays here ecigs
d6 96 these are more common responses
here so please
g6 d4 24 Queen d4 is it's you know
that's that's the way to play if they
play the early g6 you play Queen takes
the
for you create pressure so night 96 96
because I wanna be war okay 96 so looks
like you know the theory here so Queen D
4 out of 6 e 5 oh yeah this is this is
I've seen this before in chess we have
when we say theory basically there is a
database about 5 million games and in
this database we have all the games are
kind of stored so and there is a way for
you to look at and see like how many
games played and who is playing so sort
of do your research and figure out what
is the theory that the most people are
following so okay this is correct c4
Queen b6 so you play correctly or not he
didn't okay so Queen b6 played capture
check c5
a safari is a bit of a move that you
know you you're not really following the
development so development is important
so I would have likely to go Bishop III
here if you ask me we should be three
it's just no hesitation it's a move you
just simply go we cannot go wrong with a
move like Bishop III here you're
developing a piece you're getting ready
to go along castle or bring the rook
into the game so those moves are if you
feel the move cannot be wrong you just
play it okay so see 597 we should be
three then rook b8 one Castle II five
nine a for now the only move Knight a
four because there is no other way to
protect it so this is sort of became a
little bit of weakness okay and you play
d4 he is going to take rook before
Bishop e7 Bishop c4 rock d8
f3 I like your position can you playing
good chess here 98 don't like this move
yeah
this is not a good move when you put
your knight on the original square it
came from it seems you know things are
after this move yeah but okay it's at
least you can go night f8 if you you
know not sure what to do instead of
night b8 Sims yeah
g4 Bishop d7 I like g4 to rook g1 you
need to explain this move because this
doesn't look quite natural this move
yeah but g5 always has f5 you know
now look g1 has another idea I want to
point out because the black wants to
play h5 and when he plays the move rook
g1 it stops h5 idea because now Y can
just simply take maybe you can take and
if ruk takes you have route g6 and if
politics then it's just really bad you
go to g7 so but it's true t1 here it's
not the most natural move here it might
be okay still to play this move one of
the other ideas here yeah that that's a
very natural idea you go rook hg1 next
move you want to play Bishop to h6 after
which you're threatening to play Bishop
g7 and the rook is trapped and then
probably Bishop f8 is the only move then
you have some f4 ideas because the King
will be on this line okay yeah okay so
you played rook g1 Bishop c8 before okay
protecting your pawn on c5 in some point
what you need to do is you need to
maneuver this night because there is no
future for the night here
so you need to maneuver this Knight back
to c4 or d3 yeah because the night is on
the rim and there is no unfortunately
this pawn is doing a really good job
stopping you from coming in on b6 so you
need to kind of reroute the night on c4
and maybe go to d6 so which case six
Bishop e6 takes aha so you miss Bishop
e2 move
because if you didn't miss that move
then at least King takes yeah you still
have a good position if you take with a
king so basically you got to always
watch out for this kind of moves when
the bishop when the bishop has this long
diagonal you have to look at all the
squares the bishop can go to and here
after you play g4 you weaken the f3 so
now Bishop e2 is very strong and we have
a fork here now you're losing a pawn
here now we still have some chances here
look here
Bishop takes f3 now you bring the knight
one c4 this is a good idea we should
back 94 King g7 group d6 here okay
because if you go Bishop c8 then
opponent can develop his Bishop ya go
Bishop g7 so that's an idea for him if
you go rook these six here now he
probably has to go Bishop g7
yeah I mean computer [ __ ] it's good say
some ideas okay let's take a look here
who can find a nice combination here for
white that wins the pawn Knight takes e5
Dark Knight takes e5 correct now has to
take back follow it up check so if the
King goes back here or f8 it's a mate so
he has to play Bishop f6 and continue
take check Bishop check on d5 King g5
and Bishop f3
so you actually it's a very nice
combination about 4-5 moves you actually
win a pawn back and now you threaten to
take on c6 on the other hand the King
has a very strong square to go to on f4
so yeah I think white is still better
here but like rook c8 you might need to
play the reason I like white because
this night is really bad so you go King
g3 yeah this is this is I think a
probably a big advantage actually for
white because the knight is not coming
up and you can probably move this King
away now you can even go to a 6 so you
can probably try to go to C 7 and try to
go Knight d7 perhaps so there is a check
ok so we can play check probably kimchi
fire back and then go
cookie maybe even here because I really
would like to put my king only three
here then I don't have to worry about
this upon going anywhere and the king
coming in and if you go 97 then I think
the pin is very strong yeah King g3
another should be winning and if you
play through p7
what is black threatening to do take the
pawn on c5 right
a tactical idea and I take c5 and if you
take the rook you can take back so what
movie you need to play here to stop that
idea and force them to go back to c7
okay that doesn't really do too much I
take same comes back
Bishop 86 yes that's the strength of a
bishop can defend and in one move can
suddenly attack and the knight cannot do
that usually because then I immediately
attack like from the other side of the
board say the bishop was doing a good
job protecting the weakness but sadly
now is attacking has to go here now we
can take pawn put the Kings only three
so you can really get out of this pin
and we can play a 4v5 eventually break
through here 96 you can probably losing
still maybe I could have played more
accurately but I think this should be
still quite comfortably winning and
taking on c6 taking on e5 and I can even
sacrifice my bishop to for this Jeep on
if it's going to even get there so you
just simply start collecting the pawns
here okay yeah so this is so what you
can do did you think about this move
rook t6 or you just start it just huh
yeah that that's the that's the reason
why we want to have advance our pants
into the opponent's territory so we can
get squares like d6 see that pawn on c5
that's your strength because it's in his
position so you can use that to put a
piece on d6
so this is a good square for your rook
so you're okay if you do that Bishop c8
fishbase 6 H 6 now g5
if you take then block takes rook c8 and
but he's still up material now
g5 is good g55 maybe this move that I
think the Flatbush man and if he goes
king g6 what can you do it looks like
black has this strong center here and he
is about to advance absolutely takes
Knight f7 check or 94 actually works -
yeah so this is what you had to do so
when you're down upon if you keep
sacrificing pawns for some unclear
compensation eventually you'll be down
too much okay so you down one pot a lot
of positions you can save actually if
it's opposite color bishop so here I
think it's practical for you to take on
h6 because if you get into some opposite
color and game positions you can have
good chances to hold
okay so g5 trying to see what you're
trying to do with this so it takes takes
sorry that's right so you end up
actually getting one pawn back
Bishop d5 it should be seven yeah Oh a
six rookie - interesting
so if Bishop takes you want to play
Knight f7 check so it has to take back
with a knight nice pin if Knight takes
d5 this is what justin is trying to do
check and see six but what is the
evaluation here King c7 you probably
have to take back with the poem right no
can we play h6 see there's always
bouquet five ideas probably look t7
takes
yeah should be a draw I think should be
a drawer I don't think there are any
problems here yeah but he took here now
97 here and if 90 f7 just give up the
rook I guess your knight is trapped
there on h8 yeah it is very complicated
this was a long game or this was a yeah
yeah a three plate King g7 took rook d8
now you're down upon and c6
and now you're losing the other pond why
did you push this Xu you're not sure
okay but what's the logical thing to do
here let's try to understand in this
kind of positions it's an end game
already right so which piece needs to be
closer to the action here King right so
your king is on c1 so it's better to
bring the king a little bit closer and
then exchange the rooks so you'll be
closer to the center so what you can try
to take in just go King B to here and I
don't think you can just push this point
I think in fact if you push this pawn
you give up the d6 square so I wouldn't
even want to push the pawn yet I would
probably I think you have pretty good
drawing chances here it's not easy to
convert this position yeah but one one
thing don't rely on the computer too
much you know like even if it says draw
computer will beat us with any color
here you know so it's it's important to
just that you can play the moves and use
the engine but don't rely on it too much
like even if it says equal it's still
it's still possible that your opponent
can go wrong and you can even win this
position with white it's possible it's
not completely out of question to the
white can win this yes it's exactly a
mistake yeah you just your king is too
far look at the gap here it's a big gap
here you know it's just you create a
weak you just created the weakness and
you die maybe you can Queen but the new
Miss B should be six
yeah but maybe you shouldn't trade that
list here if you trade for sure you lose
the pond Roxy - but then you asked in d6
so it's better you just you just see
Justin push the pond thinking that okay
I get this past but I can do something
but in fact it created a really big
weakness here on these six King c7 now I
put a blockade
true-true yeah yeah and another thing to
mention here the pawn is protected by
another pawn so that means you don't
need to keep a piece to protect your
pawn but once you push then this pawn
needs to be protected by some other
pieces so then those pieces are not
going to be active because then we
occupied by defending the weakness and
in the games of the game as we saw
actually you just end up I think losing
the pawn here bishop sig takes takes
yeah Knight of seven here great black
over your drawing okay are you going to
reveal you are you going to are you
going to reveal who's the opponent here
okay the plate they're much stronger
than 800 sighting Wow yeah well this is
a very complicated game for a 800 rated
player right knee all this complication
so it must be a provisional okay great
thank you very much for coming and see
you next week